welcome to the video series of mobile
explained in three minutes where I
explain a concept in Mobile in three
minutes or so in today's installment
we'll talk about adapters and linkers
these are oligonucleotide sequences that
are useful for DNA ligation they are
Ultra useful in terms of cloning so let
us learn this process in bit more
details adapters are chemically
synthesized oligun nucleotides which has
one blood tint and one sticky end
whereas the linkers they are chemically
synthesized oligonucleotides which has
two blunt ends
all these sequences are useful for
cloning experiments but how let us see
that so in cloning experiment things are
simple we restriction digest our insert
and the vector with same restriction
enzyme combinations so here you can see
with these two restriction enzymes we
are going to digest our Vector as well
as our insert
and that would generate restriction
fragments which would like it to each
other with the help of the enzyme like
is and thereby our cloning is down we
would put it in the bacteria and grow
them
but things are not really easy in real
life sometime it is also possible that
there are
restriction site mismatch that means the
insert and the vector doesn't have
similar restriction sites and that is
why in this particular case you can see
the vector has a blunt end whereas the
insert has
sticky ends on both the sides on the
other hand side we can see the vector
has the sticky ends but in one side of
the
insert there is a blunt end so blunt
doesn't really like it well with the
sticky end in this case we need another
element that is known as linkers or
adapters now if we add a proper uh
adapter
then this thing can easily like it with
the vector backbone and make our cloning
process much easier
so in terms of experiment things are not
that difficult adapters would be another
solution so you have your plasmid which
is restriction digested plasmid you have
your insert which is also restriction
digested now while you like it
in addition to these elements you have
to add the light adapter so when we add
the ligase enzyme all the buffer which
contains ATP with all of these elements
we expect that this particular fragment
combined with adapter should be ligated
properly with the vector backbone that
would ensure a proper and successful
cloning
so after that things are very simple we
have to perform the classical
transformation experiment and next day
if we are lucky we would see the colony
now these are the advantages and
disadvantages of using adapter or Linker
it makes it possible to overcome the
problem of restriction site mismatch but
sometimes ligation efficiency is a
problem and that's why it doesn't work
that well I hope you get an overview
you can get more notes and flashcards in
Facebook you can support our Channel
using super thanks
see you in next video